endlose piraten pathetische reden und
eine militärische leistungsschau in drei
tagen feiert russland wieder den sieg
über nazi deutschland am 09 schon in den
letzten jahren nutze der russische
präsident dieses datum zur
machtdemonstration die spannende frage
wird sein wird sich putin hinstellen und
verkünden die ruhmreiche russische armee
hat nicht nur nazi deutschland in die
knie gezwungen sondern auch die ukraine
oder kommt es zu einer
generalmobilmachung und putin ruft
vielleicht offiziell den krieg gegen die
ukraine aus darüber sprechen wir mit
christian mölling sicherheits und
verteidigungsexperten der deutschen
gesellschaft für auswärtige politik
schönen guten morgen was erwarten sie an
diesem 9 wie wird putin den tag nutzen
also ich habe erstens wird ja keinen
sieg verkünden
einfach weil der nicht da ist und ich
denke das wird man in den russischen in
der russischen öffentlichkeit auch nicht
verkaufen können die kämpfe im don was
halten an die minimal ziel die man sich
gesetzt hat die putin sich gesetzt hat
sind nicht erfüllt deswegen ist es dann
eher wahrscheinlicher dass putin zu dem
instrument greift und den krieg aus ruft
das ist jetzt kein krieg gegen die nato
das ist im grunde genommen wenn man so
will eine technische maßnahme nach innen
es erlaubt ihm sehr viel mehr soldaten
auszuheben also sozusagen menschen in
uniformen zu stecken sie zu trainieren
aber auch die wirtschaft besser zu
kontrollieren sie haben quasi ein
kriegsrecht dass sie über das land
verhängen und damit mehr möglichkeiten
in den alltag der leute einzugreifen
weil natürlich den russen an der front
zur zeit die menschen das material
losgehen aus dem umfeld des ukrainischen
präsidenten selensky heißt es zu einer
art gegenoffensive sei man erst so naja
nicht vor juni sozusagen in der lage wie
könnte denn überhaupt ein militärisches
sieg von der ukraine aus seen oder kann
es den überhaupt geben einen
militärischen sich ja also ich glaube
man dass sich unter solchen sieg
begriffen nichts maximales vorstellen es
ist zurzeit extrem unwahrscheinlich dass
die ukraine schafft russland komplett
zurückzudrängen aus all den gebieten die
russland seit 2014 gesetzt hat was man
sich vorstellen kann ist eine art von
minimal sieg das würde bedeuten die
ukraine schafft es all das gebiet was
sie jetzt zur zeit hält auch weiterhin
zu halten das alleine wäre schon ein
sieg ihr weiterhin zu halten als
hauptstadt und
angesehener verhandlungspartner für
moskau zu sein noch da müssen uns
erinnern putin wollte eigentlich mit
kiew nicht weiter verhandeln hat gesagt
dass menschen zweiter klasse die
regierung erkenne ich nicht an all das
ist jetzt schon erreicht dass er das
anerkennen muss von daher hält die
ukraine das durch da hat sie im grunde
genommen gewonnen und dann würde
sozusagen eine verhandlung wieder folgen
die dann hoffentlich zu einem
längerfristigen waffenstillstand führen
könnte ja das ist eine deutsche hoffnung
dass wir dann alle hoffen es gibt
sozusagen happy end das muss ja nicht zu
enden das muss man sich auch vorstellen
in dem augenblick in dem die waffen
schweigen bedeutet es auch dass beide
seiten zeit haben ihre arsenale wieder
zu füllen soldaten zu trainieren neues
material zu bekommen und die frage ist
ja sind die kriegsziele auf beiden
seiten so weit erfüllt dass auch die
diejenigen zu sagen die öffentlichkeiten
die den präsidenten ski und putin
unterstützen sagen okay das reicht uns
es gibt meldungen darüber dass die
russische armee in der russischen
enklave kaliningrad atomare simulationen
durchgeführt hat wie bewerten sie solche
meldungen das ist glaube ich etwas was
wir seit jahren also spätestens 2014
sehen das ist für russland erstens
gedanklich immer dazu gehört die
nukleare seite zu konventionellen seite
mit dazu zu nehmen und wir
interpretieren im westen natürlich immer
sehr ich will nicht sagen hysterisch
aber sehr aufgeregt man muss einfach
sagen das gehört für putin mit dazu
immer mal wieder zu zeigen ich habe die
nukleare option
es ist aber nichts wo wir jetzt zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt davon ausgehen müssen
dass ein atomschlag vorbereitet vielen
dank an christian mölling sicherheits
und verteidigungsexperten der deutschen
gesellschaft für auswärtige politik wir
werden später noch mal mit ihnen weiter
sprechen vielen dank so gerne